in my world you know
i think it's pretty accurate but i
thought laverne did a great job what do
you guys think most expensive resorts in
morocco i realized the clues were there
all along she put it all on my heart
give me back that money please why you
being like this is so dramatic well
casey it's so lovely to speak to the
real casey after seeing your portrayal
in inventing anna have you watched the
whole series
oh yeah what what a ride it's it's been
arrived that's i i have to say it's
lovely and it's
crazy and it brings back memories and
it's a uh
a hard love you know it's it's uh
it's just a
it's a life experience right now i mean
to be in shondaland
to be in laverne cox land and all this
from something that was not as pleasant
as i would have hoped to experience my
feelings are mixed
but something like this experience to
have your story told and the truth come
out
is pretty amazing but you know she did a
crime and
she hurt a lot of people and as much as
you know you want to root for whoever
you know we've all been touched in a
certain way but ada also
had a great idea and i wish she was a
little bit more directed to to be honest
about it or maybe she just lost control
um
so it is
it's an experience you know to relive it
especially when you're watching someone
else play you and you and and and yeah
but it still feel like it's still so
historical having watched it all now how
accurate do you feel that the scripted
series is
it's pretty accurate i mean there are a
couple of glossy things but um
it's pretty accurate you know i i can't
say that i miss i i'm a little bit more
of a graceful gangster than maybe
laverne i mean she definitely brought it
brought it a few times but you know i'm
i'm 60 i'm 66 years old in these at the
time i was 65
with these two young women who are just
you know i wish that i could just slap
them a little bit and say let's get it
together guys you know rachel and anna
were really nice women i mean they still
are i'm sure they have there's good in
everyone but
they the choices that they both made you
know rachel you know i wish she would
have been more honest with me but i kind
of i get it you know anna i think she
was so brilliant her idea was brilliant
and she just made better choices to get
it you know ambition can read such
malice but i i for a while i was
thinking did i create this because my
you know having you know
the my life coaching
business be more like i say it's the art
of the graceful games because i like
people to stand in their power
so have you ever asked anna did i help
create this
no i i never had the chance to do that i
um and i and i know that that that's
really not true
it's just that these are the things that
you question about worrying about going
through something and you realize that
this thing is real i mean when i was you
know having to go to court and and i
went to court to support rachel and to
see and to hear all the things that i
didn't know was going on what did you
even not know
well i didn't know about the other
players i didn't know you know you know
i i knew that there was a jet or a plane
but she was like it was like oh i i had
a great time and i came back in this
private jet
but i didn't know that it was stolen
or whatever was going on what did you
think of rachel's portrayal i think she
was played as a bill i don't think that
she that that some parts i don't think
that
that it was deserving because she um she
was she was a victim like the rest of us
uh but um
i'm a little mixed because i wish that
she would have been honest with me about
you know
getting the book deal getting the hbo
deal all that stuff because i took off
work and lost money to be supportive to
her in court i think that people need to
remember that she was a victim
anna did steal from her she was she
cried she was in pain the only reason
why i even did the intervention was
because i was like i can't take this
this girl is like i was shocked i mean
near the end maybe there was some things
that were left out because she was
hiding or whatever
but you had no reason to to not believe
her have you spoken to anna at all
as of late
when she first came out of jail she um
she hit me up on instagram and asked me
if i would um meet with her to do a
reunion
and i i told her i said that you know i
couldn't do that and i don't think that
that's a great idea anyway because i had
a contract with you know with the
netflix and i wasn't talking about
anything and i even sometimes said you
have some newfound fame here i said use
it more wisely i said you're smart i
said make better choices i said i wish
you the best make better choices
and that's how we left it but i i i'm
hopeful you know i like to see the
greatness in people and i do see
greatness in and i see greatness in
rachel
and um
but i also see stupidity you know and a
waste of energy
you know and i think
i think i'm gonna go with
hoping that she will do better is there
anything else you would want to clear up
on moments that were inaccurate in my
world you know
i think it's pretty accurate i thought
laverne did a great job she really you
know it's hard to watch yourself being
played by someone else but she's so
you know she's so beautiful and she's so
gracious is there anything you wish had
been included in the show i think there
was one scene that i wish they would
have that anna left her computer at my
house that day she spent the night
because she wanted to have a reason to
come back so when she came to stay with
you that was when you knew something was
off
yeah i just couldn't turn around i was
looking at someone's daughter i was like
okay this is probably bull but i can't
take that chance because if she's gonna
if she's really going that far then she
really doesn't have any place to go
where do you stand on rachel right now
are you on anna's side rachel's side
where do you stand in switzerland
i'm standing neutral i'm a little like
you guys need to get it together
and when you're really at a place where
you are living and living your life then
maybe we can talk but i don't i don't
hate either one of them
i don't necessarily need to hang out
with them i send them love and light
you have to work hard to get what you
want i've always known that i'm building
something as a private club except
beyond the vip room what did you think
of julia's accent was it accurate i
think she nailed it
she nailed it i think she did an amazing
job i am
i am over the moon with her performance
and i mean everybody was great everybody
had solid actors what was your first
reaction when you heard shonda rhimes
involvement and laverne cox playing you
well
look at me i'm speechless
i'm speechless
shonda was that was like wow
wow and then when when shonda said i'd
like to tell you who i'd like to offer
the role to and i was like wow
i said
it's so
right
because i needed someone that could
really
i have been through some stuff and i
needed someone who can
feel that and that when i say it that
they'll understand it not try to um
you know
not not get me
and it was just perfect so i called my
manager he said the same thing he said
he says casey this is right i was like
this is so right it's so now it's so
fresh it's so it's so
it's what we need to see you know
non-traditional casting this is a
beautiful woman this is a wonderful
actress she is doing it and i am
incredibly proud that she's portraying
me i'm incredibly proud
[Music]